I think a few of the things that I've
taken from my time in the military is
definitely the core values loyalty Duty
respect
selfless service honor integrity and
personal courage anything that I've done
I try to be as helpful as I can be to
add value
my name is William Worden I served in
the U.S army
so I was born north of Detroit
my whole family is Red Wings fans hockey
just feels like it had a little bit of
everything I really enjoyed the
high-speed big checks so as a kid you
know that was always fun I've always
taken pride in what I do so I wanted to
feel like what I was doing no matter
what it was was the best that I could
put forward which is what led me to
establishing transport for troops after
working with a lot of military families
the mission of Transport for troops is
to basically fill the gaps for all the
the moving expenses that military
families have to provide just Financial
relief and free services and strategic
assistance through Partnerships
[Music]
because ultimately the goal is to pick
up a vehicle at An Origin transport it
safely to a destination and not change
hands really it's like end to end is
what we look for
to many families this is one of their
biggest you know Investments and pieces
that they own obviously they're
depending on it to arrive safely so that
they can use it
hey man hey bro how you doing sounds
good yeah long time many times the
vehicles that we're moving from military
families it's The spouse's vehicle and
that spouse is responsible for getting
the kids to school and getting groceries
service member just has to be wherever
they're supposed to be and so them not
having their vehicle uh that they're
depending on in a timely manner or at
least communication from the carrier
that said I'm going to move it that's
where we step in and just try and make
sure everybody's talking the same you
know directions
it definitely helps give me purpose
and makes me feel uplifted you know and
being able to contribute to that is good
well I got somebody on the phone for you
okay
how you doing good how are you uh David
perone from the Detroit Red Wings yeah
man
on your uh big hockey fan and you do
some great things in the community on
behalf of uh Navy Federal Credit Union
we would like to present you with a
custom Red Wing Jersey as well as a pair
of tickets to an upcoming game for you
and a guest wow thank you I'm pleased to
tell you that Federal Credit Union will
be donating to your non-profit
organization transport for troops
in our neighborhood you're a true hero
for us and we want to thank you for your
service thank you I appreciate it
thank you as well score some goals
I feel grateful that I've had the
influences in my life that I have and
that I'm able to continue to serve and
help people I don't really feel like
it's about me I feel like it's more
about the mission that I get to be a
part of
[Music]
foreign